Okay,
we are back live. Hello. Morning.
I was going to do some client work this
morning, but um I realized I didn't
actually have the thing I needed to get
started on that. So, instead, we're
going to do a couple hours now on
cleaning up puffer generally, I suppose.
Oh yeah, one other thing I suppose I
should show off.
We have some very nice experiments in
progress.
25K score
and we have several uh reaching 32K.
I believe we have 65K as well.
I just go to
Yeah, look at that.
We've got a 65k here reached as well.
Quite nice.
I believe this is like a big model
that's very slow, which is kind of
funny,
but it wins on uptime as well.
All right, cool.
Okay, let's think about the uh the stuff
to do this week for a couple moments,
shall we?
So, this is way better than it used to
be. I'd say this is not fully done, but
I'm sick of looking at this file for a
little bit.
Um,
okay. Yeah. So, all these other files
are going to get removed. No biggie.
I think the uh the test file can get
updated now, right?
I think the test file is probably the
last major claw thing where we need the
model.
I know I keep saying that, but
believe me, I want these models out of
the uh workflow ASAP.
But take a look at this. I mean, this is
2600 lines of stuff.
Let's see what we have in here.
Okay, so there's some of these that just
get straight deleted, which is nice.
a lot of these are going to just get
straight deleted. Good.
Yeah. So then this will basically this
will have the kernels. This will have
the network forward.
The network backward is no longer an
isolated call anymore.
we have the ability to just profile the
train function a bunch or whatnot.
Okay. So, I because I think that the
main thing we need here,
we need this to just reflect the So,
this is going to get like a thousand
line shorter just off of deleting um
unneeded kernels.
And then
we'll still have tests for all the
kernels. We'll have to make sure that
they're correctness checks because what
I'd actually like to do this morning.
Let me show you.
A lot of these kernels are just kind of
janky.
You know, I'd like to sort of start like
pulling little bits of this stuff out.
They're just pretty redundant looking.
I'd like our kernel code to be nice.
It definitely needs to be this needs to
be nicer.
And let's not just be um doing nothing
while this is doing stuff. Let's go look
at module CU and let's see what we can
improve here.
We have a whole bunch of torch checks,
right?
Uh, so I mean these definitely
these definitely do slow stuff down, but
they don't get called when you graph.
There's probably a flag to disable them,
right?
Let's see. This is pretty short now. We
can just kind of like go through this.
So you are allocating this is allocating
memory every time.
this is the one thing that this is
usually okay
Like this is just like a lot of busy
work.
we could have this not allocate memory.
We could have this just be
I don't know how the uh how autograd
would do would handle that though.
Yeah, I mean the main thing that I see
here is the uh the allocations, right?
if this is a class, can't I just make
this with the right data shapes and not
have to um
Wait. Fuse scan checkpoint function.
Man, why the hell is there a class for a
function?
But does Mingru have one?
No. See, Mingru doesn't even have one
because this doesn't have auto grad,
right?
So for the autograd, it's torch
autograd.
Tensor with AT1s will not be
differentable. Tensor with torch ones
will be.
Okay.
But now I don't understand why
actually. Yeah.
Okay, we have a whole big diff to
review.
Massive, massive diff to review.
But this is a quick one because most of
this is just deleting stuff that is
outdated. All right.
Deprecision float.
Okay, this is all outdated kernel. This
just gets deleted. We don't use this
kernel
strruct
updates precision
log [ __ ] x. I believe we kept
scan update precision types.
I'm just looking if it did anything
weird. This is a very uh easy refactor
here. It's mostly just deleting old
stuff.
view scan backward checkpointed. Yeah,
there are no more launch functions as
well
which is fine because this is a raw CUDA
test. This is the way it should be
built.
This gets deleted.
We don't have this entire sunk this
entire chunk no longer exists.
T
Uh,
hang on. Do we need this?
Okay, we'll let it do this for now. It's
going to need to um
There's going to be a little bit more to
do, though. Okay, that's immediately
minus,000 lines, though. I think some of
it's going to go back.
This doesn't have um profiling for the
training now though.
Oh yeah, I also didn't bother attack
checking
Let's just make sure that our
experiments are still running and didn't
crash.
They are.
This is
180 or so experiments into 2048.
We're going to have to rerun all the
experiments that we're doing now.
Unfortunately, it's like we're not at
the final experiments for puffer um
buffer five yet. Puffer four, not five.
Inhaled a bunch of cinnamon on the top
of my drink.
This will also replace the end speed
test presumably.
Only thing I have
I do have no policy.h
Wait,
this is wrong.
I don't even know how that file got
there, which is bad. Good to know how
your files got somewhere.
Okay, there you go. She using the wrong
names.
It takes so bloody long to compile with
torch though. The annoying thing
Yes, this is the right the right usage
for a policy. This one was dated.
We have this correctness check as well
which is good.
>> So, I don't even have to look away from
my keyboard. And it's kind of funny
because it'll like fly above my head and
then like kind of dodgy and stuff and
I'll literally feel like feel the wind
on my my neck.
>> I feel the wind on my neck.
>> [ __ ] it's cold.
Um, but yeah, like this is uh
>> yeah, you got to push this to the limit.
So like what is the what is what is the
pushing like you want a you want a hill
to climb. You want a ladder to
your daily scene.
Funny guy.
>> It seems like he's having a good time
building his drone stuff though. a fun
puff for infra.
well, this is weird because I don't even
think we have log co-ops and values.
That's a lot of likes you got there.
What?
I really haven't posted much stuff at
all lately.
Oh,
did this yesterday. This was cool.
I think that'll be the uh side project
for whenever I feel like.
Oh, it didn't build correctly. What I
do?
Wait.
DSO missing.
Oh. Uh,
this is weird.
Now, I really do not like how long it
takes to compile
everything.
Um, and this is I believe just because
of torch.
That's definitely another thing we're
going to want to work on.
Unfortunately, we can't run the
correctness checks without um without
torch, right?
This comes from back end
and motion.
Well, we're including the end
including popper lib directly. No.
Okay. So, there's a whole bunch of stuff
then that's just like
not
working.
No, we're going to use the static end,
but always use static end.
Nope. Torch has it directly.
The hell is this?
I still hate this. This is completely
nonhuman editable. I'm trying to figure
out why. Like where is where is the jank
that's making me not want to touch this?
How do I get rid of it?
I think it's honestly um it's probably
the setup.py build.
Is that it? I don't think that's
entirely it, though.
Okay. Okay. So now we just have to like
this is
I'm gonna have to actually like take the
time to draw out the architecture of
Puffer at some point because it's
probably way too complicated still.
This is all getting better, but it's
still like nowhere near shippable. I
mean, for as long as I'm having to edit
my own code with a freaking language
model cuz I don't want to touch it.
Like, it's not ready.
What the [ __ ] is this?
Is it not this profiler build x?
Yeah, it's it's torch extensions as
libraries.
You set up as an extension with
libraries. I don't know why.
I wonder if it's like bundled with torch
somehow.
You know, if we don't, we should just um
if this doesn't work, I'm just going to
guard the NCCL
and we can clean all that up.
Yeah, we can definitely clean all that
up.
crappy. But for now, we can do this. And
then ultimately, um,
well, I suppose it depends what we end
up deciding to profile.
we're not going to leave all these
freaking tags in.
Claude. Yeah, this is Claude. I
absolutely hate this [ __ ] though.
Okay, so this is no NCCL. Let's see if
this gets our profiler working. And I
think that the uh the move here is going
to be
well, we're going to see what we even
need this for in a second.
We definitely do want to profile the
Ford pass of the network, right?
Okay, so our log Kimx kernel
it's very bad apparently. Okay.
Are these even torch tensors? I'm
confused.
cuz it uses the checkpointed one, right?
Yeah, this is the correct one.
Check in the meantime. Uh forward call
and M speed, right?
This literally copies and pastes the
code.
So, what the hell do we need this for
again?
We just should not need puffer lib CPP
at all
is what this means.
And then we won't have the um
yeah, we won't have the NCCL [ __ ]
All right. So, this will end up working.
It's going to get work. It's going to
get worse before it gets better, but
it'll end up working.
And then of course this dict set
nonsense.
We'll do this with the file
I think we're using a couple things, but
nothing super significant.
And obviously like the sample actions
thing should not be like this.
There's just too much bloody code on
this.
Yeah, it just needs the same sort of
cleanup treatment as uh I did for puffer
lib CPP
and we will be good.
17K uh 1,700 lines
get down to like 1500ish.
Oh yeah, for uh for folks watching,
please do star the puffer. It helps us
out a lot. We just hit 5K.
Duping precision. That's fine. We can
just end up moving that anyways.
And we just not have puffer CPP
included.
That fixes most of the build problems as
Puffer Lib is where we link in um NCCL
and such.
Probably this will get turned into just
like a load to dict or whatever
Okay, that'll be way better.
So, we don't actually have to like build
puffer lib CPP on the test.
pretty much just some stuff needs to get
moved around so that it doesn't have to
be duplicated. And
I think that's most of the jank.
Frankly,
once we move stuff around so it doesn't
have to be duplicated, then there's
there are a couple other places where
stuff is just duplicated for no damn
good reason. Um,
Sway and uh using plug. No, sheep boy.
It's really really [ __ ] But the problem
is torch is also really really [ __ ] And
it's [ __ ] in a way that makes you have
like gobs and gobs and gobs of redundant
crap. And you actually have to, it's not
like if I were just writing C, right?
You actually have to do a ton of
thinking uh in order to figure out how
to not write gobs and gobs of redundant
crap. So, while I'm figuring everything
out, um, this is nice because if I
specify a single refactor op, like it
needs to get everything needs to get
updated in like 10 places.
The goal is to get all of the training
code and stuff into a actually human
editable form so that people don't
actually need to be using stupid claw to
edit it.
You'll notice if I'm used if I'm uh when
I'm doing like CN work, I'm using it way
way way less. Um if at all. Like I used
it yesterday on a C project, not for
even editing my own code, but just for
like scraping through a reference repo
and like trying to find stuff in a
really big other codebase. But I think
you'll notice the more I have nice
actually correctly written compact code
bases, the less I use it.
So it's kind of ironic like the worse
your code is, the more helpful the bot
is. So, it's just like
it's basically 100% skill issues, right?
Like you if you think that it's useful,
it's probably because your code bases
just suck
because it's very very clearly stupid.
And actually the simpler a codebase you
give it uh the more obvious it is it's
stupid because you actually can't easily
track the ways in which it is stupid in
a big bloated codebase because nothing
makes sense there anyways.
Okay, we uh our correctness, it deleted
our correctness check on PO loss.
That's some [ __ ]
And
uh there's no way to check sample
logits, I believe.
Is there anything we can do for sample
logics at all?
I actually kind of don't think so,
unfortunately.
What else has duped logic? Let's go look
where we need the bots. Exactly.
So, I mean, the solution to this, right,
is to work hard to actually build good
compact stuff. um which is also much
much easier to edit and understand and
also makes it easier to solve actual
problems. Uh and then basically to tell
anybody who wants to introduce a bunch
of crap into your project to go [ __ ]
themselves.
It's kind of the only way you can do
anything nowadays.
I mean, you basically have um all these
like LM slot bros declaring victory
like, "Oh, all of software is automated.
Let's move on to the next problems like
in the next year or two." When in fact,
these bots are crap and they can't build
anything meaningful.
They're really good at smoking mirrors,
though. Like, if anything, they're
superhuman at lying and deceiving
cuz they're basically just trained to
LAR. So they're really good at laring.
Okay, it's fine.
I don't see any other dupe logic here. I
think it was just the sample.
Maybe they can be shorter, but at least
they're not duping the logic.
Where is this thing? Create end speed
args.
Oh, we don't use it here. Cool. That's
fine then.
We used it in
moderately annoying, actually.
Moderately annoying.
Leave this like that then.
Okay, that ought to do it.
Then flip this 1800 lines.
I guess we'll see after like this type
of stuff goes away, right?
Yeah. So, all this is just going to go
into the models file, I guess.
Why does this need to include the
freaking Oh, it does need to include the
kernels, right?
Yeah. So, this is what we wanted. So,
basically every single time that we have
something like this,
it should get a little shorter.
Yeah, it's like just too much crap to um
for each individual test the way I have
it here.
It's probably just like each module
probably just needs a strct
at least for its outputs.
I don't know.
I mean, despite how annoying this is,
we are very quickly getting towards um
something that's substantially simpler
and more stable.
I think it is realistic that we end up
shipping, excluding this big test file,
we could end up shipping about 3,500
lines of code for the new backend.
It's a hell of a lot better than the
original 6,000.
We actually probably want to add
correctness to that.
Yeah, we can do this log prop. Wait, can
we do log prop consistency?
Is there an index op? I don't actually
know if you can do this.
We'll try that. We'll see if that
passes.
And then we got the breakout test at the
bottom, which is good.
Really annoying that there are warnings
in um
in cudigraph.h.
Oh, that's not Nvidia. That's torch.
Torch.
9:34.
Let's say uh we will finish this. I'll
commit this and then we'll also make a
nice pruning commit. We'll just like
delete all the old files that we don't
need anymore. So we'll have something
relatively
reasonable to look at.
And there's some checks. I don't know if
the checks are bad though or the um
the checks are bad or the kernels are
bad. I think it's probably just the
checks are bad.
Okay,
good.
Very good.
So now what we do,
let's open up
I want to see what's on the remote
version.
Hello user.
I want to see what is on my remote
version.
These no longer get used.
They're already been They've already
been moved.
cleaning stuff up. These have all been
moved. We're trying to get a clean
commit
much better, right?
Vecm.h does not get used anymore,
right?
right. Way better. Right.
So, if we look at puffer lip extensions,
we've got this stuff in it.
CUDA, we've got this stuff.
Nowhere near as bad.
Still too much stuff, but way less. Way
way way less.
Let's go message uh let's go message one
of our new contributors here.
All right, I just sent over the the
latest one of our contributors. See if
he gets anything if he finds anything to
do with that. Um, okay. For us now
It's still the damn popper CPP file,
isn't it?
But overall, even with all of this,
what's this mock C++?
Okay, even with everything, this is 4K
lines.
Even with absolutely everything, this is
4K lines.
things I'm not going to do. I'm not
going to do the pure C back end. I'm not
going to massively refactor puffer.
What are the main things then that we
have left? What's the stuff that still
bothers me? Let's see if I can figure
that out real quick before I got to go
to the gym.
Oh,
we're not going to be able to do
benchmarks. Actually, I forgot we have
uh this sweep is still running.
191 experiments though.
It's pretty good.
I do find it weird that this didn't just
like keep going, right?
It's got this perfect score over time
curve. Why can't you just run this for
longer?
Possibly
an artifact of learning rate
learning rate decay. I don't know.
But okay, we have breakout. We've got uh
we've got our M's training.
We have multi- burrito sweep clean up
or sweeps.
I clean up
difficult.
Obviously there's constellation but we
are waiting on that for later.
Not a terrible idea to put some time
into constellation.
I'm trying to think about like the real
real stuff
profiling
like what's the stuff that's really
preventing me from feeling like this is
close to delays.
Honestly, the biggest one is probably
the end speed still being jank.
Like the M speed is not scaling the way
I expected to, and I've had a couple
different reports of people saying that
as well.
So, I think probably figuring that out
is the most important thing. Um,
the rest of it is kind of generic
cleanup. Very minor feature addition.
Yeah, the experiments. But the
experiments are already starting to look
pretty good.
I think it's mostly just the end speed
stuff.
We just use the benchmark end and then
do MS speed profiling.
That's probably the last thing in here
that really still feels jank, you know.
Okay, we'll do that either later today
or tomorrow then. I also have client
work to get done. I'm waiting on one uh
them to send me over one thing, but I
got to get I got to start getting ready
to
get over to the gym. So, I'm going to go
do that.
Uh
2048 is at 24K score in 15 minutes. Uh
17 minutes I believe, but it's also at
22K score in
7 minutes.
Pretty good.
Oops.
If you're interested in my stuff and
you'd like to support me for absolutely
free, star this puffer on GitHub. Feed
him a star. You can join the Discord to
get involved development and you can
follow me on X for more RL content.
Thank you and I will be back